good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight one thing about
americans they love australia most
americans have never been there it's an
awful long way away but when americans
think of australians they imagine a
freer tougher version of themselves
steve irwin crocodile dundee
that kind of thing so there's a huge
reserve of affection in the united
states for australia its culture and its
people it's also possible that most
americans us included have not updated
our assumptions about australia in a
while and the modern reality is a little
different from what we imagine case in
point two years ago june 2019 the
federal police in sydney raided the
offices of the australian broadcasting
corporation that's a state broadcaster
abc
they weren't
at all
unclear about why they were raiding the
offices they said it out loud just days
before the raid abc broadcast
allegations from a whistleblower that
embarrassed the government of australia
this whistleblower said that australia's
military leaders had killed civilians in
afghanistan including children and had
lied about it
the abc broadcast that story it wasn't a
crime to broadcast the story and
australia's federal police didn't
pretend it was instead they served the
broadcaster with the warrant that
authorized them the police to cover up
any evidence of the australian
military's misconduct think about that
for a minute
the warrant and were quoting it allowed
police to quote add copy delete or alter
any material they wanted to alter on the
broadcaster's computer
that's not the kind of thing that
happens in a free country to put it
mildly and yet australia's military and
police forces never suffered any
consequences for doing it in fact many
australians the polls show supported it
they rewarded their military with
hundreds of millions of dollars in new
spending most of that money was intended
to keep australians safe from the malign
influence of chinese authoritarianism
even though that
seemed a lot like chinese
authoritarianism itself
two years later what does australia look
like well it looks a lot like china did
at the beginning of the pandemic that's
the sad truth we showed you those
pictures from china at the time people
being welded inside their apartments to
starve the guys in hazmat suits forcing
people into quarantine boxes and then
driving away to some unknown destination
at the time our public health officials
including tony fauci told us that
nothing like that could ever happen in
our country or in the west
but that was wrong because those things
are now happening in australia
this is what happens in australia for
example if you try to leave your
apartment anthony carrum knows he's
covered positive when he steps into this
public lift already breaking so many
rules he doesn't bother to cover his
mouth as he sneezes and splutters the 27
year old is still infectious but has
gone missing from his wentworth point
apartment a warrant now issued for his
arrest
this 27 year old chap
who apparently has expressed the view
that he doesn't care less whether he
spreads the virus
is one example of the worst of the worst
so a national manhunt for a man who
sneezed in an elevator that's the state
of play in modern day australia not
everyone in the country is on board with
this but since australians were
completely disarmed by their government
several years ago there's precisely
nothing they can do about it so it's
accelerated
look at what's happening now
they're being crushed this was the scene
in melbourne the second most populous
city in the country in the past month
watch
[Music]
we're trying to
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the government cracking down on islamic
extremists dangerous revolutionaries in
their midst no just ordinary australians
complaining demonstrating peacefully
against the lockdowns beaten by police
there's a lot of footage like this from
australia and in a moment we'll show you
more
but something that's not immediately
obvious from the american vantage is
that this isn't all of australia the
whole country is not locked down in
australia most of the lockdowns are in
the eastern part of the country that's
where the capital of the country is
that's where the federal government has
the most control the western part the
less populated part of australia
meanwhile which is home to most of the
country's national resources isn't
locked down at all fifty thousand fans
just crowded inside a stadium for rugby
match in perth the capital of western
australia no one was beaten with night
sticks or hosed by the police
the rugby match was not a super spreader
event western australia has had
virtually no cases of covet
how does that happen how does western
australia not lock down but remain
virtually covet free
simple by controlling its borders
western australia did not let thousands
of people stream in from anywhere they
wanted to in the world they're not texas
they didn't care about protecting their
borders they weren't worried about being
called racist it seemed common sense and
it worked
and here's the revealing thing
in australia the federal government is
angry that western australia has closed
its borders
they want that part of the country to
open those borders really why would that
be
well according to abc news australia's
government is quote arguing that western
australia's internal border restrictions
are a drag on the national economy end
quote
well that's kind of interesting because
the problem with australia's economy
right now does not come from western
australia closing its borders
it comes from the lockdowns those are
the biggest drag on the national economy
ever conceived in australia so were
those police swat teams beating people
for going outside
coveted mandates are a far greater
threat to australia's economy and its
social fabric then covet itself
here's the health minister of queensland
in eastern australia explaining that
outdoor mass mandates are absolutely
necessary because of two new coveted
cases that's two not two hundred
thousand or two thousand
but two watch
what these two new cases mean is that we
will be extending immediately uh the
directive in relation to mask wearing
to the gold coast
okay so we want to pause for a minute to
give you a sense of the scope of the
pandemic in australia
to date covet has caused 1300 quote
recorded deaths in the entire country
australia has 25 million people now that
1300 figure includes people who quote
died with probable covid what does that
mean we have no idea no one's ever
defined it in alberta canada and this
might tell you something the health
minister just announced that anyone who
stays home from any illness will be
counted by the canadian government as a
covet patient
then she pretended she didn't say that
because it's obviously insane but it's
on video so we know that she did
in australia the government has adopted
a similar standard anyone who leaves
home apparently is also being counted as
a covet patient here's a man in
melbourne this sunday who made the
mistake of walking a block from his
house
he leaves a block but he has no what do
you mean he has no reason to be here he
doesn't have a valid reason to be out
today he wasn't wearing a face mask hold
on he has a face mask in his pocket he
was just smoking a cigarette he just
came to get lunch with me
and the reason i didn't have a master
because i was having a cigarette i've
got two masks in my pocket like what
else do you want me to do
here's the interesting thing apart
that's obvious authoritarianism it's
terrifying that that could happen in a
civilized english-speaking country in
australia of all places but you'll
notice the police never ask the man if
he's been vaccinated you think that'd be
the first question you'd ask because
vaccination works doesn't it that's why
it's mandatory right
that's an important point because
publicly australia's leaders are still
pretending that vaccination status
matters in new south wales again in
eastern australia
one official promise that the
unvaccinated will be allowed to retain
their freedoms
the message to the unvaccinated is that
you will not achieve any further freedom
unless you get vaccinated and a further
further and final message to regional
new south wales there will be
individuals in regional rural new south
wales who choose not to be vaccinated
who will lose their freedoms on the 11th
of october
no more freedom if you don't get the
facts
but they will arrest you for being
outside smoking a cigarette a block from
your home without a mask and not even
ask you whether you've been vaccinated
so vaccination status is that important
as a health matter wouldn't that be the
first question you asked but they didn't
even bother
meanwhile in the same australian state
new south wales officials are telling
people that whether they are vaccinated
or not they're not allowed to go to
church
in the name of jesus lockdowns are over
in the cities of new south wales it's
unclear what passage this pastor is
preaching from but it's not the public
health order his church the christ
embassy in blacktown is in lockdown
hard lockdown there was no qr code on
the door costing the organisation five
thousand dollars each of the thirty
adult worshipers find a thousand dollars
whether it's a soccer match whether it's
a church service
it doesn't matter you cannot you cannot
gather
as they did at blacktown
oh so you have to get vaccinated to have
any of your freedoms but even if you are
vaccinated you're not allowed to go to
church
so what is the point of vaccination
why do the federal government and
australia
lock everybody down if there's no
actual way to stop the lockdowns and
more to the point why do they want open
borders in western australia
if closing the borders actually has kept
the population safe well they want open
borders there for the same reason they
want it here
in new south wales one official
the state's health officer explained it
out loud watch
we will be looking at what contact
tracing looks like in the new world
order and yes it will be pubs and clubs
and other things if we have a positive
case there
the new world order she said it out loud
this is a really interesting story
what's happening in australia and what
it means for the rest of the anglosphere
very much including us and maybe that's
why
globally most media organizations have
refused to cover it that comment the one
you just saw about the new world order
got barely any coverage at all in fact
all the footage we showed you today is
mostly being ignored in the united
states
why
because it's possible what's happening
in australia might be instructive to us
in the united states
in just two years the australian police
went from raiding newsrooms to beating
people in the streets so maybe the
lesson is things can change very quickly
one moment the english-speaking world is
mocking china for being dystopian and
autocratic
the next moment they're aping china and
hunting people down who are two blocks
from their own homes and smoking a
cigarette hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else